so we're looking at a community to the
level intervention that again is
targeting and trying to change social
norms it can be used with a variety of
at-risk populations in a variety of
venues as well it was actually tested
with multiple populations specifically
with gay men in bars african-american
women in low-income housing and male
commercial sex workers pol works with
opinion leaders from those populations
to encourage safer sex norms so the
theory and evidence behind it this also
is based on the diffusion of innovations
theory that again says behavior trends
you know typically and predictably
follow the adoption of opinion leaders
and we saw this really clearly actually
through the D up training when you
actually go out and watch groups or
social networks of people you can see
people actually like listening to these
opinion leaders even at like little
things the evidence that they found was
that it significantly reduced
unprotected anal intercourse reduced
number of sexual partners and it also
increased condom use among participants
so the core elements for pol it's
directed at an identifiable target
population in very well defined
community venues so as you noticed the
three groups that it was studied with
were very specific gay men in bars
african-american women in low-income
housing so it works best when it's very
targeted ethnographic techniques used to
find the PERT persons who were popular
well liked or trusted they actually used
techniques for that over the life of the
program fifteen percent of the target
population size found in the venues get
trained as popular opinion leaders so a
big part of the program is to go and
find these people to train and use as
peers you teach the popular opinion
leader skills for initiating informal
Risk Reduction messages to their friends
and acquaintances and actually dieppe is
neat because although we're not
highlighting it today it's a
adaptation of pol for young MSM and so
it does the same thing it tries to get
people to take messages informally back
into their own social networks some more
core elements of pol it teaches popular
opinion leaders characteristics of
effective behavior change messages
targeting Risk Reduction attitudes norms
intentions and also self-efficacy groups
of popular opinion leaders meet weekly
in sessions that use instruction some
modeling from the facilitators and
there's extensive role plays and
exercises to help the POS refine their
skills before they're sent off to do the
work POS also set goals to engage in
risk reduction conversations with their
friends and their acquaintances so they
actually have a certain number that
they're expected to go out and talk with
popular opinion leaders conversational
outcomes are reviewed discussed and
reinforced during training sessions and
then another part of it is that logos
and symbols and other things are used as
conversation starters between popular
opinion leaders and others so they might
develop some tool to bring out with them
to use as a method of engaging people in
conversation ok so now I'm going to ask
Brian King he's the director of HIV
prevention and education at health and
education services incorporated in
Massachusetts to talk to you about their
experience with popular opinion leader
thank you so much happy to be here I'll
of popular opinion leader and my staff
do too but it wasn't always so so I want
to put that out there to a global
background I work for health and
education services which is very large
Human Services Agency in Massachusetts
we cover Essex County which is north of
Boston on a pretty wide County and the
program is actually called the game by
men's health program it's been existence
for 15 years we're funded by the
Department of Public Health
Massachusetts to do HIV STD prevention
with gay men by men MSM transgender men
and we're actually now in the process of
changing her name to prism which is more
inclusive of all of those all of those
folks that were in contact with i'm the
director brian has you heard and this is
a Kirsten the condom queen she is one of
our outreach workers everyone seems to
know who Kirsten is if you live in the
North Shore and her in the gay community
she's everywhere and then the other
full-time outreach worker is 10 or
Blanche debris she's not always Blanche
but that's how she's recognized
instantly we thought branding them is a
really good way of people recognize them
in the community so the strength of our
program has always been being really
consistent and very present in the
community in multiple places we do
outreach at bars clubs sex parties
private parties on the internet public
sex environments and everything in
between and that's really important
which poised us to do pol i think is
because we have established
relationships and all these venues with
bar owners bartenders the mayors of the
cruising area all those guys know these
folks and what is really helpful is that
they might see Ken in a public sex
environment or in a sex party giving out
condoms or hanging out in the kitchen
talking to people and then they see him
in front of the bar
and we're doing a van you know a testing
van like like Sam was mentioning and
they say oh they trust him because they
saw him in that place to they think he's
not just some guy from some agency was
coming here just for this one night
we'll never see him again so he has a
sense of who this person is another
thing that a it's been a strength of our
program is innovation we'd love to try
new things and often the state uses us
as their guinea pig so we were the first
in the state to do outreach at sex
parties in Massachusetts we're actually
I think Stefan would say were the first
in the world to do HIV outreach on
manhunt and then we were also the the
first in the state to do the testing
then we are coordinated with a
northeastern university to do that and
now as a statewide program which is
fantastic but we used to have her like
once a month and now we have her twice a
year because everyone wants are you know
but well here's a little thing about the
van so as you all know i mean the CDC
recommends or mandates that we do Abby's
and Debbie's and that was obviously an
issue when you're you know doing things
a certain way like why do we have to do
this now so you know it wasn't
necessarily easy we tried community
promise which involves collecting Risk
Reduction success stories from men
printing the stories and training peer
advocates to distribute and talk about
the stories with the target community it
didn't really work well for us but the
idea of sharing stories we thought would
work really well so in popular opinion
leader incorporates that and that's a
huge part of it and what we liked about
it was that people are sharing their own
stories our risk reduction messages are
really based on their own experiences so
it puts a pretty valuable tool for
fostering a sense of community because
people are sharing their own successes
another thing is that we really believe
in the harm reduction philosophy and
assets based approached we really try to
avoid any sort of language that
stigmatizes gay sex or shames same-sex
design
and I think a lot of people especially
the guys we work with have a history of
saying okay unsafe sex is equated with a
shame about my sexuality it's easy to
put those things together so we try to
be very very focused to help guys
differentiate that and what I really
liked about pol is that it's really
focused on assets based and it can be
because it's so adaptable that you
really can do anything you want with it
the core components are basically
recruit people who are popular we
already knew the population very very
well so we knew who was popular so
recruitment wasn't an issue it might be
a harder thing to implement if you're
just starting a program and you don't
have a huge presence in the community
you might have to establish that first
four before bringing on pol at least
that's in my opinion i'm not sure if it
would work as well if you didn't really
have that presence so as I was saying
one of the major motivations for using
pol was actually the unique population
we have nadia also works in Lynn so she
knows Lynn is a very multicultural place
that's what the the sort of the focus of
our work there's a high rate of HIV very
low in very low income very
multicultural and what's really
interesting about the gay community it's
very unseated so for example we have the
24 year old brazilian guy who's
roommates with a 30 38 year old filipino
guy and they're both fens with the 65
year old gay man who lives with his
ailing mother I mean it's really like a
family so we thought pol was going to be
really effective and it has been as I
said about the recruitment it wasn't too
difficult because we already had
established these relationships with bar
owners and and folks so we already knew
oh we know this guy is the most popular
guy and this guy is the bartender and
and in the end we've had four that we've
been doing for six years now we've had
bar owners bartenders bouncers go-go
dancers regulars HIV positive HIV
negative
black Latino Asia Pacific Islanders
transgender we've had heterosexual who
are really involved in the community or
at the bar sometimes you know at a gay
bar there are some people working there
who are straight lesbian women bisexual
so it's been a very eclectic group that
we've had and we've had about 200 people
who've gone through pol and the bar
itself that we focused on 47 central
this is the mention right there to where
we do the van is Fitz probably on a
really hot night maybe maybe 150 200
people if they're packed in so having
done 200 people over this many years has
been you know something that we're
pretty proud of another way that we kind
of help with recruitment is that we the
same way that these guys are talking
about we do it the training sessions not
in the office we do it at someone's
house apartment right next to the bar
it's like a Tupperware party and for
that community it works really well
people come over Kirsten cooks this
great food and often that's one of the
top ways of recruiting people's like I
should come by Kristen's sausage peppers
and onions are amazing you know that
gets them there and and one thing that's
interesting of the 200 people we've done
I think I I think there's a myth around
you know that Oh HIV you know everyone
knows the facts about HIV gay men know
all the facts probably about ninety
percent of the guys that have gone
through pol did not have the correct
information about HIV transmission they
thought they did they thought they knew
what they were but when we actually did
it we realized that this was new
education for a lot of them successes
and challenges what like I said we
started off we didn't really like pol
because we had to rip it apart I think
what's kind of you have to do with this
curriculum it's it is outdated it is
from the 90s it is sometimes even non
harm reduction based some other
recommendation
have nothing to do with harm reduction
so we really went in and ripped out a
lot of the really heavy informational
parts it's a lot of parts in the
curriculum if you look through it that's
a you know you suppose just stand there
and say this is how HIV is transmitted
this is this this is these are the
sexual behaviors whenever we possibly
can we get that information from the
guys so we do an HIV 101 game show you
know where they have to answer questions
there two teams keeps them you know not
tuning out the same things with the
sexual risk reduction behaviors instead
of naming off this is safe this is save
this is say we break them into two
groups and say all right you guys have
to come up with as many as you can in
like five minutes you know and then we
list those and we talk about the pros
and cons of each one because the
epidemic is very different now than when
this was written people have different
types of negotiation around safer sex
some guys don't use condoms at all some
of the monogamous relationships that we
try to include all of that subtle
information and conversations about
those things in the in the pol I mean
it's not just about condom use one of
the major things that we've seen in and
we've seen some of this data already
today a lot of the guys we work with and
ones that have been infected have been
infected through perceived monogamous
relationships often after the second
date the idea is I think about I go back
to like the 50s when you're going steady
and it's like when she going to put out
you know and it's it's like well we
haven't been going steady that long well
with gay men that we're working with in
that we're seeing it's the when do we
not use the condom anymore how long
we've been going steady we don't have to
use the condom anymore and there's no
discussion about status there's no
discussion about testing it's just this
sense of trust we saw some of the quotes
about a feeling of affection so it is
for these guys we're hearing this a
sense of intimacy and Trust of sci-fi
love someone they would never give me
HIV so so those are some of the things
that we that we use
another challenge I'm quickly going to
try to get through this is um here's a
logo another challenge that we've had is
getting guys to do the conversations is
no problem that we teach them the basics
of HIV that we do the role playing they
go out they have the conversations some
of it was documenting the conversations
is difficult another thing is that there
are these elements of an effective
conversation that are included in the
curriculum they're fantastic they're one
of the real assets of this ways to talk
about HIV in a positive way talking
about your own you know risk reduction
methods how they work for you giving
helpful hints but when you take a lot of
guys and you train them and how to have
conversations like that communication
role-playing all of that I statements
use I statements use your own experience
they go out to come back and I said well
I was telling me he really needs to use
condoms he better said they was very
focused on trying to coerce their
friends into health you know and it
often with the opposite effect the
person kind of shuts down and you know
like oh you know I'm not going to talk
to him about this anymore even though
these guys were very very popular they
it's sort of like a social norm this is
how you you know you get this message
out there and the other issue was
documenting a lot of the guys would come
back with real great success stories
about conversations but actually didn't
how many how do you know you did well I
think I did around seven or I did around
15 I talked to a couple people here and
there what you talked about we talked
about HIV it was hard for them to kind
of focus a document that even if we gave
him journals I mean who's going to walk
around one of the journal when they're
at the bar right so what we did do is we
tried some of the logos this is one that
is a conversation starter we had these
posters that said do you know and then
the guys wore t-shirts that said I know
this was developed by one group of pol s
they really liked the idea so people
would see the things and go no you know
I don't what do you know and then that
was
sation starter that lasted a little
while and but what we were still having
those same issues so we started this
thing called the success report and what
it is is literally hereís a bunch of
questions we're going to go out we're
going to interview our friends ask them
these questions and then they're going
to interview US and then that way it's
like an exchange doesn't feel like that
I know everything I'm going to tell you
everything about HIV it's more like you
tell me what you do I tell you what I do
it's an exchange of ideas it's a little
bit more equal and it being assets based
we really wanted to start off with a
sense of success and get it the idea of
a positive way of looking at behavior so
tell me a recent success you've had that
can be you know I got up today what
water who helped you reach this goal my
alarm clock does this is sex impact your
life in a positive way yes I got to work
on time you know so then we say now
we're going to talk about success in
regard to your health tell me about
something you've done recently to
improve your health is coming physical
or emotional health I left my boyfriend
he was jerk what made it possible for
you to do this I'm talking to my friends
you know they were they agreed they saw
the way we were together and realize you
know you should get out this
relationship how does this impact your
life in a positive way feel better about
myself I feel relieved one health issue
that has an enormous factor on the gay
community as hiv/aids what are your
thoughts and experiences of hiv/aids I
don't know I know a couple friends that
are HIV positive what do you currently
do in your own life to reduce the risk
of HIV infection either for yourself or
for your partners you know well I I just
only sleep with guys that you know that
look healthy and what helps you do this
you know I got a good sense of people
know how to trust people how does this
impact your life in a positive way you
know keeps me safe these are kind of
this is might be what they're getting
back but then the way it works is that
these pol have been trained to give very
much more specific answers about what
they're doing to prevent HIV so then
when they answer they can be more
explicit like I use condoms I keep them
by the bed you know this is the
behaviors that I do and then I'm six
test flat and so far the guys had loved
this because they've covered all of the
things that are elements of an effective
conversation and they've been able to
you know have really even deeper
conversations about what health even
means to somebody what success is so
it's always about the assets instead of
coming and what don't you do what should
you do so now it's a we're out of place
where you know we're having a lot of
success with it and I definitely
advocate you know this program
specifically because it's so adaptable
and and we've done that as much as we
can so thank you so much